the idea that everyone gets a blue
ribbon this is terrible too because
every child is rewarded regardless of
how well they performed if they're all
rewarded to the same level you actually
flatten the dopamine curve yes everyone
might feel no celebrated but you
actually are lowering motivation for the
given activity this has a whole
landscape of research in back of it
related to Intrinsic versus extrinsic
reward strongest motivation is always
going to be intrinsic motivation if you
reward kids or adults for something too
many times even if they like that
activity the propensity to do that
activity will be reduced but if you
reward without effort or without success
arrives without prior effort destroys
people is why hard work followed by
reward great that is powerfully positive
would mean that just arrives because you
say oh you're here so you get reward
terrible and this is why rewarding every
little positive thing that a child does
you know their favorite thing eventually
diminishes the value of that thing and
diminishes their ability to get
motivated on their own